il ya quand même des choses jacques que
la sérénité de l'âge vous a amené à
refuser
on va faire une interview c'est fini
tout ça jacques en quoi ne croyez-vous
plus en la justice quels sujets de
conversation ne vous intéresse plus
la frivolité quel animateur télé ne
supportez vous plus je suis dans
l'indifférence figeac lorsqu'il s'agit
de juger quelle fille n'avait voulu voir
les films un peu qui triture le nombril
et qui m'agace
qu'est-ce que vous n'écoutez plus comme
musique quand j'écoute à peu près toutes
les musiques parfois ce même celle que
je n'aime pas pour pouvoir en parler
de quels auteurs n'hésitent pas les
livres je crois hélas que mon travail
m'a condamné à lire tous les livres et
je vous dirai que j'y prends beaucoup de
plaisir et même souvent avec des mauvais
quelle faute de français cnpf êtes vous
plus je ne sais pas si j'ai fait
beaucoup de fautes de français
mais par exemple je n'aime pas qu'on
dise par contre 1 j'aime bien qu'on dise
en revanche voilà qu'est ce que vous ne
dites plus aux femmes
il est difficile de dire je t'aime
lorsqu'elle a décidé de le dire à une
seule qu'est ce que vous ne faites plus
aux femmes
or leur fait tout dans le regard de quoi
ne vais vous plus envie de parler dans
les interviews de moi qu'est-ce que vous
n'avez plus en france une certaine
indifférence au pays lui même
quel voyage ne vous intéresse plus tous
les voyages m'intéresse je suis prêt
demain à partir pour le bout de la chine
d'ailleurs je vais sûrement revenir au
vietnam vise 8 et jallet
c'est pas loin non parce que c'est vrai
tout à l'heure tout est alors je parlais
de l'asie mais j'ai beaucoup aimé
l'afrique
ouais j'ai voulu car vous avez failli
vous l'avez shooter ou quoi alex là je
m'attendais pas un commerce commentaires
de ce genre vous saviez une série ce que
c'est il faut jamais provoqué dans la
vie je n'ai qu'une seule qualité je suis
persuadé que vous l'avez je sais écouter
qu'est-ce que vous ne mangez plus des
concombres je ne peux pas ça mais
dispose
ah oui c'est la seule chose d'ailleurs
ce pas quand tout roule en reste quelle
drogue ne prenez-vous plus l'opium intel
est un tel souvenir un que le reste
vraiment c'est de la gnognotte quel ça
ne vous fait plus forte et semer c'est
les fameux fonds encore son tsb qu'il
faut rêver ça plaira beaucoup à ma femme
qu'elle rêve me faites vous plus je rêve
beaucoup je m'invente des histoires et
peut-être qu'à la vérité
le romancier et la victime de ses rêves
quelle position ne pratiquez vous plus
quand vous faites l'amour jeu j'aime
bien toutes les positions mais j'ai le
droit d'en rêver chance